the virus was Swift and deadly after
emerging near your home in New York City
it spread first to London then to Tokyo
eventually wiping out more than 99% of
the global population but you you were
lucky you were one of the few thousand
people on earth with immunity who
survived so now what your first step is
to stock up an average midsize
supermarket can sustain one person for
about 55 years 63 if you're cool with
eating the cat and dog food as you scan
the aisles look for canned food some of
which can last for up to several decades
and bottled water because once the power
grid goes down your municipal water
supply will run dry in a matter of weeks
or even days you'll also want to grab
some super glue in case you get injured
it can easily seal wounds in the absence
of stitches and make sure to hit up
hospitals pharmacies and even vet
offices for antibiotics and painkillers
vets treat animals with many of the same
medicines that we use for humans such as
the pain reliever hydrocodone and the
antibiotic doxycycline once you're
packed you'll want to hit the road
because without electricity to cool the
fuel inside nuclear reactors pressure
could build up and cause the reactors
containment building to fail especially
if it's old or was poorly maintained and
that could release toxic radiation
within a 50-mile radius or greater and
even if your city or town isn't near one
of these plants you'll still want to
seek isolation because in the aftermath
of the Apocalypse
there will be decaying corpses strewn
about the streets oh yeah it's gonna
stink but they'll also attract animal
scavengers and infectious bacteria that
can harm or kill you if you
too close so yeah a country home is
looking pretty good right now so it'll
be tough to figure out exactly where to
settle it'll need to be close to fresh
water but also far away from major
rivers because many dams could
eventually collapse without anyone to
maintain them you'll also want to be
near fertile soil so you can grow your
own food once your grocery supply runs
out and of course we'll want to be at
least 50 miles from a nuclear power
plant so somewhere north of Edison New
Jersey would probably be a good bet
after settling in you'll need a steady
supply of drinking water so it's a good
thing purifying krieger lake water is
surprisingly easy you can bring it to a
boil
fill up clear plastic water bottles no
larger than a liter and stick them in
direct sunlight for at least six hours
or add a few drops of a 5% liquid bleach
solution to a liter of water but farming
your own food would be a lot tougher if
you're able to scavenge a gun or bow and
arrow you could hunt there are over
100,000 deer in New Jersey which is more
than 11 per square mile and each one
keep you satisfied or at least alive for
two weeks or more but wouldn't it be
easier just a farm assuming you could
plant the right crops yes corn for
example might be everywhere but many
modern varieties are hybrids and often
can't reproduce on their own so they
won't grow from one year to the next
that's why you'll want to scavenge seeds
of heirloom crops which reproduce
naturally try searching small farms
backyard gardens and garden centers for
beans potatoes and some kind of leafy
green that way you'll have a supply of
protein carbs and lots of vitamins now
with crops in the ground things will be
looking up you know relative to life and
post-apocalyptic times but you know what
would make it better
electricity you could store perishable
foods like the deer you killed
not to mention have light heat running
water and whatever else might help you
live more
comfortably at first you can scavenge
motor generators from roadwork or
construction sites and Fife in gasoline
and have abandoned cars to power them
but eventually you'll want to nab some
solar panels along with big batteries to
store the power they produce abandoned
golf carts might be a good place to look
they're powered by deep-cycle lead-acid
batteries which you could discharge many
times without significantly shortening
their lifespan ah now you can finally
relax all that's left is repopulating
the planet
[Music]